انا المرشح الوحيد القادر على انقاذ
امريكا من المتعصبين والاغبياء بهذه
الجمله اعلن دونالد ترامب عودته المبكره
للمشهد السياسي في امريكا والهدف
انتخاباته
2024 خطط كثيره بعضها جدليه كتصريحاته
اعلنت ترامب عن تحضيراته للترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه بدءا من
الداخل الامريكي ترامب تحدث عن بناء مدن
فاضله اطلق عليها مدن الحريه ستحقق احلام
الامريكيين وفق وصفه وستعيد فتح الافاق
وتعطي مئات الالاف من الشباب وجميع
العائلات التي تعمل بجد فرصه جديده لملكيه
المنازل ليس هذا
فحسب حيث ان مخططه 2024 سيشمل ايضا
الولادات الجديده في امريكا لافتا الى انه
سيطلب من الكونجرس دعم مكافات المواليد
للاباء الصغار للمساعده في اطلاق طفره
مواليد جديده وفق وصفه اما عن الازمه في
اوكرانيا فقال ترامب بان لديه مخططا يبدو
انه سحري فهو بحاجه فقط لاربع وعشرين ساعه
لايقاف تلك الحرب بين كييف وموسكو وفق
قوله دائما لا بل سيحتاج الى عشر دقائق
فقط لاقناع عقاده الدول في الاتحاد
الاوروبي برفع حجم مساعداتها المقدمه الى
اوكرانيا ان فاز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله
قبل ان اصل الى البيت الابيض سوف اقوم
بتسويه الحرب الكارثيه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وستتم تسويتها بسرعه
ولن يستغرق الامر اكثر من يوم واحد اعرفوا
بالضبط ما ساقوله لكل منهما لقد تعاملت
معهما جيدا لقد تعاملت جيدا مع بوتين
اتذكرون عندما قالوا ان ترامب يعطي الكثير
لروسيا حقا قال لي في الواقع اذا كنت
صديقي فساكره ان اراك عدوي
وشدد ترامب على ان الولايات المتحده في
وضع اخطر من اي وقت مضى بسبب خطر استخدام
الاسلحه النوويه ونشوب حرب عالميه ثالثه
وتساءلت ترامب عن سبب تمويل اداره الرئيس
الحالي جو بايدن لكييف بهذه الاموال
الهائله في الوقت الذي يكتسب فيه انتصار
اوكرانيا على روسيا في هذا الصراع يكتسب
اهميه اكبر بكثير للدول الاوروبيه منه
للولايات المتحده هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق مايك بومبيو ان الوقت قد
حان لتتجاوز الامه المرشحين السابقين
لمنصب الرئيس في تصريحات بدات تستهدف
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
[موسيقى]